my mom was a warrior and the grand
tradition of the bravest strongest
warriors from ancient greco-roman
history my mother was a warrior that's
Sean Astin lovingly reflecting on the
life and legacy of his mom Patty Duke
the actress died on Tuesday at the age
of 69 Sean was there in her final
moments there was a nurse in the room
priest there was mine stepped out of me
and we watched her receive this blessing
and when it was she was in great pain
before it started and at the end she was
in peace she was a piece and you
commuted an atheist you a skeptic and
had not you could be whatever you want
but what just happened in this room is
you know indescribably beautiful and
then and then in her last moments she
was at peace the Lord of the Rings star
opened up to ET about his mother's life
praising her for revealing her diagnosis
with bipolar disorder in the 1980s and
later becoming a major advocate in the
mental health field she was one of the
first you know public figures with a big
public profile who did that the more she
opened up the more she shared of her
pain the more she revealed how
excruciating pain can be turned into
bliss it's very instructive for people
Duke was an oscar-winning actress with a
career that spanned more than 50 years
but most importantly Sean said she was a
pillar of strength she's a warrior and
applies to each aspect of her life she
suffered so much throughout her life she
had a lot of joy in her life but above
all the way I think of my mother the
thing that
gives me such joy and reverence for her
is it above all else use a warrior